hello viewers I am live and in color in
the CBS this morning Toyota grew green
room with sheku Khan a Mason also known
as cello Bay do you like being called
cello bass right it really is all right
he became an instant sensation after is
mesmerizing performance at the Royal
Wedding of Prince Harry and Megan Marco
in May his album inspiration charted
number one on classical charts in the US
and the UK he is a student at the
prestigious Royal Academy of Music in
London was recently named one of Time
Magazine's next generation of leaders we
like that he makes his us concert debut
this week in Seattle we welcome you to
the United States a coup thank you thank
you have you been here before to the
States this isn't your first trip or is
it it's not my first time now I've been
a few times I was lost in New York a
year ago a year ago well let me just
tell you from my perspective what what
happened to all of us who are watching I
was there I was there at the wedding I
wasn't covering it I was on a balcony
outside the wedding but we were
streaming it live we were carrying it
live and when you started to play
everybody knew him said who is that guy
oh my god he's so good oh my god he's so
young and so then we thought how did it
come to me so how did it come to be that
you ended up playing at the Royal
Wedding I'm not sure exactly but I was
about a year before the wedding I was
performing a charity event at which
Prince Harry was attending so he would
have heard me play there and and then
the January before the wedding I was
contacted and then called by by Megan
Megan Michael asked me to perform at the
wedding
well I'm thinking shake oh well we know
how this came to be Harry saw you and
then he clearly liked what he saw and he
says to Megan I saw somebody really
great so your phone rings you pick it up
and I want you to take me through the
conversations was it make it on the
phone did somebody say Megan's on the
line and what did she say yes sir I was
I can't remember exactly where I was
coming back from rehearsals and I got
this phone call and I answered and they
said we've got we've got Megan Michael
here she'd like to speak to you and yeah
she just asked me to have for the
wedding and of course
I said I'd be honored to perform at that
and yeah look to the date and I was Risa
and you were free well what would we
have done shake ooh if you had had a
booking that day well that's a night but
look we're lucky we're glad that you
didn't okay so did she give you did they
give you direction on what they would
like you to play or did they leave it up
to you a bit of both there were pieces
that cally pieces that they laid they
liked and suggested there were pieces
that I suggested them to do you listen
to and so it was a combination of us it
was a combination yeah but they were all
three pieces that I know very well and
enjoyed playing so it was fine and we
should point out it's not like well
first let me ask you this were you
nervous when you were asked to play were
you as you were getting ready did you
think this is a royal wedding millions
billions of people would be watching or
did you just think I'm a professional I
I got this I mean generally before I
perform I don't get you don't get
nervous
um obviously this was a performance very
different to what I'm used to but yeah
in time I just okay
what enjoy it okay cuz this is what I
want you to understand audience he is he
is well known in classical musical
circles so it's not like they just grab
some random Joe off the street who could
play well you were really considered at
the top of your game at what you do I
want people to understand that you've
been playing the cello how old are you
now 19 19 you've been playing the cello
for since you were six I read something
that your mom said that once you got the
cello they couldn't get it off of you
you come from a family of how many kids
there are seven of us so you're one of
seven and everybody plays a musical
instrument yes so it was important in
your family definitely and for me
growing up with music all around was
such kind of an inspiration
are you the only one in the family that
plays the cello I know I have two
sisters who lose their positions what
are their instruments do your siblings
play piano and violin and viola so your
mom says when the first time that shake
ooh when he when he became at that he
that she couldn't get the cello off of
you
what was it about the cello that
attracted you to that instrument lots of
things I used to love listening to a
cellist that I really admired and that
was one of the things that really
inspired me and also I think the child
is very lucky in the repertoire that it
has it has lots of there are lots of
wonderful pieces written for the cello
that I enjoy mm-hmm
discovering and I think it's an
instrument that has such a range of
sounds and so I enjoy it and you haven't
we have a treat coming up for you
because che cose has agreed to play two
songs for us but I want you to get a
sense of who he is and his love for this
instrument because I'm told this
instrument is 400 years old it's about
400 G and that you never ever let it out
of your sight that it's with you always
you should hear well you hear these
stories about you know famous musicians
leaving you know Stradivarius is you
know very expensive violins or very
expensive instruments in a car you could
never see that happening to you I really
hope not
you know Sheikh who I hope that too
thank you
so at night is it in the bedroom with
you is it always in you I didn't say was
in the bed but is it in the bedroom
where you can see it yeah yeah do you
worry about it
I didn't worry as long as I am very
careful with it does it have a name that
doesn't happening it doesn't know why
did I have named it no why
I mean I've only had this for yeah and a
half I'm still getting to know it I
don't know it seems that's something
that means so much to you do you like
the name Gail I do my name is Gail he's
like oh no I'm definitely not naming it
that you're making I'm just throwing it
out there and by the way Gail in this
country is a unisex name - Bell GA Wylie
but if you wanted to be a boy could be
GA IL or can be GA le or could be GAE oh
just Mull that over oh but I am curious
about growing up in a musical home was
it something that your parents said all
of my seven children will take
music lessons are they musicians
themselves I'm they both played
instruments when they were younger and
what did they put you didn't even play
the cello yeah my dad played the piano
on each other okay my mom hi piano
lessons mm-hmm and stuff but they're not
musicians anymore and they went on to do
other things but they still loved
listening to music and so that's
wonderful support to have that but when
we were younger they got us into loads
of things we did lots of sports and what
sports do play so I play football okay I
mean soccer it's not raining let me see
I was very prone to stuff I knew that
all right go ahead and then yeah I was
into maths and physics and lots of other
things but music was the only thing I
really loved and can see myself doing
awesome I know after the after the Royal
Wedding you were referred to as cello
Bay and cello Bay for viewers that may
not be the hip and cool viewers cello
Bay normally means somebody hot that's a
hot kind of I like this guy so how did
you feel about being called cello Bay
because you know we're just meeting
today for the first time you do seem
very low-key are you very low-key I'm
maybe yeah very very relaxed but you're
very relaxed did you like being called
cello Bay that's that is a compliment
actually it is it's um
yeah it's really really nice and I think
what it hopefully shows is that one of
the things that I really tried to do is
bring classical music to as many people
are saying yeah yeah I think bring it to
young people who haven't had the chance
to hear this yeah wonderful music at all
I think is something really important to
me and so I think it's great
well then that's what I think to shake
who that really stood out number one
you're a person of color I was saying to
you before we went on camera that I
interviewed Lewis Hamilton actually last
night who is the only black Formula One
driver who's also from England as you
know and he says one of the things that
he that he thinks about is growing up he
didn't see anybody that looked like him
and that he really does make it a
mission to bring this sport to as many
people as he can and certainly to
diverse communities and I get the sense
you feel
that as well yeah I think it's
definitely very difficult to see
yourself doing something if no one who
looks like you is doing it and for me I
grew up around my siblings playing music
and I was always encouraged from for me
on age but I think I think it's really
important that I use my my position now
to bring classical music to an audience
and inspire people who haven't who
wouldn't normally get the opportunity to
hear this music well I will say this
you're as I said you're very well known
in your industry of classical music but
for a lot of people that was the first
time we were seeing you and hearing you
did you get a big response did your life
change after that when you were walking
down the street did they say hey how you
doing
it was I mean obviously I was performing
in front of so many people who are
hearing me for the first time and I
really was honored to have the
opportunity to do that and I would say
my life is changing in many ways but my
focus on developing as a musician is
still it's still focus yeah my favorite
scene but were you surprised that that
that that performance attracted so much
attention and did it attract attention
from girls from boys from what from all
over it was yeah I was free did that
take you apart no I just I enjoy I
haven't opportunity to perform to people
and meet with new people
okay so yeah alright cello Bay also
known as shake ooh what would you like
to play for us - I know you said you
would play two things yeah let's do
let's play one and then we'll chat after
you play what are you sure I'm the first
piece savage let's play is the prelude
from box first suite in G major Bach
root and six suites for solo cello and
this one that I'm gonna play now is
probably the most bone inside okay do
you need me to do anything maybe you can
sing along if you do you need my help in
any way shall I hold the cello okay here
we go
[Music]
beautiful from whoa you know you seem to
I was watching your wrist your wrist
flows so fluidly over the strings what
do you you seem to be in a zone what are
you thinking when you're playing are you
thinking anything
you may call thinking lots of different
things and the music that I I play is
music that I've kind of lived with and
studied for for a long time and it's I
try to really get to the depth of what
each thing in the music means and so
when I'm performing I'm just thinking
about that how do you feel when you're
performing um I think it depends on why
I'm performing okay how do you feel
right now right now I think that's a
piece of search I think there's kind of
a whole world within just that piece of
music and there's so many wonderful the
harmony isn't so I really just enjoy
playing now when you're not with your
cello when you're not playing what other
kinds of music do you like
are you a country-western fan I'm a
massive reggae fan regular okay I've
grown up listening to Bob Marley yeah
yeah yeah yeah so when you're sitting on
a plane and you're traveling is that
what you're and you have earbuds in or
is that what you're listening to
yeah I mean usually on a plane then
train I'm asleep if I'm not then I would
be listening to people and when you're
not when you're not in school you're a
student you're a new second year
sophomore year but you're in your second
year in college what are you studying
music what do you I know I study music
that's it that's that's it I know it's a
royal music academy but I didn't know
you don't have to there are no that no
other kind of courses to take I'm not I
don't know yeah yeah it's just purely
alright which I love I clearly you do
and when you graduate what would you
like to do I think I think with studying
music even when you finish and you've
graduated you never finish learning and
developing so it's not like I graduate
and then
I'm a professional musician I think
there's always more to learn but I hope
to continue to perform to perform around
the world the reason why I ask is I go
back to Lewis again yesterday at this at
this interview with him I played a tape
when he was 6 and he was just starting
go-karting you call it go karting with
the with the and using the he had
exquisite I hand coordination and even
at at six four six years old he there
was an interview with him saying you
know it's my dream to one day be a
Formula One driver which is so cool to
see that from the time he was a little
boy in this little go-kart with the
number 44 which is he has today to see
your dreams come true when you sit as
you sit here today and when you were
growing up is do you have a dream job or
a dream for your life that you would
like to see other than involving music
are not involving music I think I've
always from when I was very young
enjoyed performing to people and I think
for me my my dream is to always just
perform around the world in as many
places that I come into as many people
as I can as you can well you're making
your debut in the United States your
head your we're in New York of course
live in the green room at CBS this
morning but you're leaving us and going
to Seattle
I am yeah what were you what are you
going to do in Seattle so your debut
yeah I'm really looking forward to
playing that I've never been to Seattle
before and when playing Tchaikovsky
Rococo variations which is a piece for
cello and orchestra so I'm playing with
the Seattle Symphony Orchestra there so
yeah I think they're very lucky that
they get you and what's your this will
be your last selection for us today what
what do you want to close with and well
I thought I really enjoy listening to
Bob Marley yeah and so I have an
arrangement of one of my favorite Bob
Marley songs which no woman no cry
that's the only one I know okay no woman
no cry shall I sing along he's like no
thank you
okay
[Music]
very I could have done that part very
nice but I wouldn't dare touch it
congratulations thank you so much for
coming to New York really it was an
honor to meet you because I know how
good you were that day and I can only
imagine what's to come of your career
just know this we are cheering you on
and good luck in Seattle thank you very
much bye